l'Ukraine déclare avoir reçu des chars
de combat Abrahams de fabrication
américaine ces chars viendront renforcer
les troupes de Kiev plus d'un an et demi
après l'invasion russe
les premiers chers américains Abrams
sont déjà en Ukraine nous les préparons
pour renforcer nos actions contre les
occupants et ce sera renforcement
significatif nous travaillons également
à l'obtention de toutes les autres
capacités militaires nécessaires
Washington a promis de fournir 31 chars
Abrahams à Kiev au début de l'année on
ne sait pas exactement combien de chars
ont été livrés ni combien de temps il
faudra pour qu'il soit déployés sur la
ligne de front
plusieurs dizaines de chars léopard de
fabrication allemande ont déjà été
envoyés en Ukraine ainsi qu'un petit
nombre de chars challenger de
fabrication britannique l'annonce de
l'arrivée des premiers chars Abrahams
intervient après que Washington a
déclaré qu'il fournirait à Kiev quelques
systèmes de missiles tactiques de longue
portée ces systèmes ont été utilisés
lors de la guerre du Golfe dans les
années 90 et en Irak au début des années
2000 le prochain armement occidental que
Kief attend c'est lui l'avion F16 lui
aussi américain l'Ukraine prépare les
infrastructures pour l'accueillir et
forment ses pilotes auprès d'alliés
occidentaux